♪ ♪
SPEED TO BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT
THOUGH IT IS HERE MARY FROM THE
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE COMES IN THE
FORM OF SUBPOENA FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Laura: THE MOVIE SO
DESPERATE THAT EVEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AS A
FUTILITY IN THIS.
SAYING A CLEAR SIGNAL OF THE
AGGRESSIVE TACTICS THERE CHINA
USED TO FORCE COOPERATION OF THE
WHITE HOUSE'S FORMER TOP LAWYERS
WHO MOST LIKELY BE ABLE TO
INVOKE ATTORNEY TO MANY
QUESTIONS.
GENERALLY NOW IS MATT WHITAKER
FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY UNDER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
SO MY CLOSE FRIENDS OTIS TO
REALLY FEELING ABOUT THE
STRENGTH OF THE SO-CALLED CASE?
>> THEY TRY TO KEEP ENTICING
THAT THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING TO WATCH AND THEN WHEN YOU
SEE WHAT THEY HAVE AT THIS JUST
DOESN'T TELL ME ANYTHING.
I HAVE CONCERN THAT THIS CROSSES
THE LINE OVERLY PEEKING INTO THE
MOST CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
OF THE WHITE HOUSE THEY OPT TO
TRY TO GO AGAINST MARK MEADOWS
TRY TO HOLD THEM IN CONTEMPT AND
PROSECUTE HIM.
THIS IT WERE NOT A PROSECUTOR.
NOW ARE GOING OUT FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THE CONSTITUTION IS DESIGN FOR
ACCOMMODATION IN THIS
INTERESTING DANCE BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATION OF AND THAT BRANCH
DOES NOT SIT DOWN AND IT'S
REALLY AN AGGRESSIVE UNNECESSARY
STEP.
>> Laura: IN THEIR LETTER THEY
SAID THAT THEY NEED FOR THE
INFORMATION OUTWEIGHS ANY
CONCERN ABOUT THE SEPARATION OF
POWERS HERE I GUESS IT WOULD BE
PRIVILEGE?
>> THAT OVERSTATES THE CASE I
WOULD SEE THE PRESIDENT NEEDS
CONFIDENTIAL ADVICE FROM HIS
CHIEF OF STAFF AND IS
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL AS A
MINIMUM.
>> Laura: HOW DO YOU OPERATE
AS PRESIDENT WHEN THE DEMOCRATS
GET A POWER?
THEY DON'T WANT THEM TO BE ABLE
TO OPERATE SUCH A THING THIS IS
WHAT IT'S REALLY ALL ABOUT?
>> THEY DON'T WANT DONALD TRUMP
TO OPERATE AS PRESIDENT THIS IS
BEEN OBVIOUS EVER SINCE THE TOOK
OVER JANUARY 2019 I WANT TO
TESTIFY TO THE PUT THEM BACK IN
THEIR PLACE.
IN ALL HONESTY THIS IS A STEP
THAT THEY WILL RUE THE DAY.
>> Laura: IF I WAS THEM I
WOULDN'T WANT TO CALL THEM UP
THERE.
BACK IN AUGUST OF 2020 FEDERAL
APPEALS COURT RULED THAT HOUSE
DEMOCRATS COULD SUE TO FORCE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WHITE HOUSE
CONGRESS AGAIN TO COMPLY WITH
WHAT CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENA IS
SAYING THAT THEY HAVE A
LONG-STANDING TO COMPEL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS TO TESTIFY
THESE DOCUMENTS.
THIS IS FROM DONALD TRUMP'S
IMPEACHMENT THIS DOESN'T FOLLOW
ON TO WHETHER INSTRUCTS JUSTICE
AND THE IMPEACHMENT THING IS I
PROVIDE ANY PRESIDENT FOR THEM
CALLING?
>> IF YOU READ THAT OPINION THE
COURT REALLY ANCHORS SORT OF
OPINION THAT THIS IS AN
IMPEACHMENT AND ITS VERY
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW WE ARE IN A
SPECIAL OVERSIGHT AT BEST THE
SERTA HAVE NO ABILITY TO
CROSS-EXAMINE THE TIGHT
OPERATION ON A THINK THAT A
COURT IS GONNA HOLD THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT AS AN IMPEACHMENT
THEREFORE I THINK THAT WE LETS
ADDING TO ITS MARK IS IN A HOLD
OBVIOUSLY HE TOLD THE PRESIDENT
A LOT OF THINGS IS NO I THINK
COMPETING INTEREST IS POWERFUL
AS A NEED FOR FINANCIAL
COMMUNICATIONS AS YOU WOULD SEE
IN THIS COMMITTEE TRY TO FIND
OUT WHETHER HE LUNGED OVER AND
GRABBED THE STEERING WELL.
>> Laura: SOME COLORFUL
LANGUAGE PERHAPS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE HASN'T EVER BEEN
DONE BEFOR